autres états occidenitititititin
ne serait pas pire qu'ailleurs
- Depuis le début de
la pandémie, le Québec dénombre
par 100 000 habitants.
Ça, c'est deux fois le taux
enregistré en Ontario.
Mais selon François Legault,
ça ne veut pas dire que la
qu'ailleurs.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
premier ministre du Québec
- Les chiffres de surmortalité
parce que ce sont leananananana.
Quand on regarde les chiffres
qui sont dispoououououour toutes
les provinces puis les États-
Unis jusqu'en septembre 2021,
on voit quoioioioioioioioioioios
au Québec qu'en Ontario,
que daststststste du Canada,
qu'aux États-Unis.
- La surmortalité, c'est
ungrgrgrgrgrgrgrgrgrgrgrgrgrgrgr
l'impact d'une catastrophe comme
grgrgrgrgrosse vague de chaleur
ou encore une pandémie.
FRÉDÉRIC FLEURY-PAYEUR,
démographe
- On prend l'ensemble des décès
survenus au cours d'une péri
à ce qui aurait dû normalement
survenir s'il n'y avai
d'éléments perturbateurs.
- Mis à part la vague de décès
de la surmortalité, au Québec,
ressemble en effet à celle
observée dans le reste
québécoise est également
inférieure à celle observée
dans le nord-est des États-Unis,
par exemple.
Pour les 18 premiers mois
de la pandémie, la surmortal 3 .
La proportion s'élève
4,7 % dans le reste du Canada
et à 16,8 % aux E S S S S S S Sé
comme indicateur,
d'un endroit à l'autre,
la façon de déclarer un décès
lié à la COVID varie beaucoup.
- Par exemple, une personne qui
un cancer en phase terminale,
le cancer comme cause initialede
cause secondaire. Mais on va
et c'est la façon de faire,
tel que recommandé par l'OMS.
- Si le Québec utilise
mondiale de la santé, ce n'est
pas le cas ailleurs au pays.
La Dre Tara Moriarty,ororororo,
met d'ailleurs en garde
le gouvernement ontarien
et les autres provincesueueueues
fournies par le Québec
reflètent probablement ce qui
se passe ailleurs au pay l l l s
dans le reste du Canad
est en réalité bien plus élevé
que ce que montrenfifififififif.
SIMONA BIGNAMI,
en démographie, UdeM
- Très bientôt, les autres
provinces
vont se retrouver dans la même
situatbebebebebebebebec.
- Mais on ne peut pas vraiment
dire que le Québec fait pire
Ce qui est juste, c'est
que le Québec calcul
mieux et plus rapidement
les décès liés à la COVID.